j'accueille elie semoun
lee
je viens l'entente il ya une demi heure
je sors du spectacle paris justement
prêté au théâtre du gymnase là c'est ça
au théâtre du gymnase où elie semoun
interprète elie semoun se prend pour qui
dans une mise en scène de roger louret
coécrit par muriel robin tout à fait
merci au revoir
non c'est infini non non c'est pas fini
tu as passé deux heures par jour pendant
combien de temps dans la cuisine on a
écrit on a mis chez pas 5 6 mois écrire
ce spectacle deux heures par jour et
qu'ils y six mois dans la cuisine oui
j'ai pas pris un kilo
c'est elle qui les a pris des kilos en
sans commentaire oui on a écrit dans sa
cuisine tu passes ta lieu symbolique les
cuisines j'adore mais moi j'adore
si tu connais la jeunette alors je suis
sorti avec elle pendant six mois
impressionnant les mecs qui raconte des
histoires comme ça jean ba voila j'ai
été violée à quatre ans après j'ai vécu
avec des loups pendant cinq ans la sorte
de prison j'ai été pendant cinq ans je
suis poursuivi par des mecs qui veulent
me tuer je vais dire la vérité même si
je meurs demain
j'avais dit que demain benko ils vont
tripler est-ce que tu savais toi qui
avait des hommes politiques qui faisait
braquer des banques
vous savez ça toi non moi je pensais que
c'était des gens honnêtes c'est pas
surpris je pensais qu'ils étaient
honnêtes que quand on était au pouvoir
on était toujours correct je suis étonné
d'avoir dû entendre parler de sa vie
pourquoi il vous a parlé anglais vous
êtes anglais ce nom oui choqué c'est
génial tu essaies là c'est la vraie
rosbif quoi rêver rouge c'est tout à la
fois la carie dentaire est bien plus
ment on est en france
d'accord on parle de ton spectacle
ouais c'est humour parfois noir que son
boss mouais bah ouais ouais les plaisirs
galerie de portraits tout à fait correct
hockey pierre mattei kevina exact kevin
na waie milliards il vient toufik way
plus un vieux plus un langage plus nos
mots hystérique
ouais tous des monstres quand même c'est
tous des monstres serment - c'est au
fond c'est assez pathétique c'est drôle
mais c'est mais plus et noir et plus
c'est pathétique plus ça me plaît c'est
un spectacle j'ai bien que soit le rang
oui beaucoup
d'accord et je n'aime rien oui mais
quand moi j'ai plein de collègues qui
sont venus me voir et on se demande
toujours quand il ya des gens dans fin
des connexions là ils analysent furuya
comment il a trouvé cette vanne la
comtesse de dieu nos îles à paris gaulle
et du tonnerre
si l'âge aidant loin alors il ya un truc
surtout qui est nouveau ouais c'est que
tu fais maintenant du stand up sur tu
t'es tu parles avec le public je me
lâche un peu c'est la grande nouveauté
même ça ce que j'avais l'habitude de me
cacher derrière des habitudes chez moi
je me cachais un peu derrière les
personnages et maintenant je me lâche un
peu le public me fait un peu moins peur
et je parle avec ouais ouais ça c'est
bien c'est un mélange de saluer à la fin
c'est nouveau mais c'est vrai que j'ai
un problème
probablement de relationnel avec la
bulle tu déteste les gens non mais de
peut-être un peu de timidité c'est
paradoxal mais c'est bizarre non sentir
énorme et les applaudissements il a
fallu que mon metteur en scène me dise
comment faire comment revenir saluer et
c'est ce que j'ai toujours un problème
je vais vu moi elle a du coup c'est tout
elle me regarde plus du tout où tu vois
moi j'existe plus là d'un coup un agent
exister ni mort ça il va m'en veux car
ça c'est de la merde
whissell shit
non mais ça marche bien spectacle
question qu'on dise c'est plein mois
quand j'y suis allé c'était ouais voilà
c'est en fait je fais de la promo juste
pour le plaisir de venir ici moi je suis
content c'est contraire à sam donc elle
aime beaucoup les français oui continue
des caméras pouvoir comique toi c'est ça
qu'il soit là il ya un pouvoir de
séduction ni bonne en anglais tony bones
les eaux comme issue à sa toile a écrit
lui moi
moi j'y viens truc doit être payée ya un
truc y aura bien une foule aïe c'est
qu'on joue du gentil ses membres
comme quoi bon alors tu parles de
dieudonné évidemment dans ton spectacle
mais ça on s'y attend un peu en asie on
a tant de temps dure à cause d'un truc
quand même c'est qu'au début de votre
association c'était c'était toi le
patron en fait c'était moi le patron oui
quand on a commencé oui c'est sûr qu'il
a gardé ses cages fait non il voulait
pas il en est des bagnoles il devrait
très bons comédiens en plus ils
n'étaient pas sains oui au début ils
n'étaient pas très bons comédiens mais
il est malin et bien intelligent très
bon très très bon et en fait vous avez
pris un producteur il a regardé comment
ça se passait a pris le président
faisait beau c'est exact c'était lui
était pas encore tarnac un juif lui
dieudonné est très forte ensuite il a
voulu vous produisiez vous même et tout
vrai mais c'est qu'à l'origine de son
grief contre les jugements ça c'est à
cause de moi qu'il est antisémite est
clair avant
résultat tu dis il est devenu plus
requinque les requins c'est vrai qu'il a
rapport avec l'argent très spécial quoi
toujours cette paranoïa persistante la
peur de se faire avoir
voilà donc c'était son obsession il
fallait qui fonde sa société qui soit
son propre patron qu'il ait aucun qui
reçoivent aucun ordre et c'est son
obsession il ya un truc qui est marrant
c'est quand vous être vu à montréal
l'été dernier dans dental health study
j'ai eu le sentiment que tout ça était
pas sérieux qu'il est dans la
provocation et que cela réussir même toi
tu arrives pas à croire complètement à
ce qu'ils racontent quoi tu penses qu'il
fait ça vous faire suivre il ya des
moments où ça me fait peur quand je
l'entends dire des conneries sur le
soi-disant lobby juif etc
et puis parfois je me dis que qu'il est
peut-être en train encore de jouer la
comédie
ça me trouve beaucoup que vous me
regarder comme ça
wade non voilà donc c'est peut-être
effectivement encore suivantes être que
ça l'étude ils sont là on peut pas être
son excuse perpétuelle donc à un moment
il faut qu'il rende des comptes quoi il
a fait ici d'ailleurs alors tu au
gymnase jusqu'au 25 juin
oui sinon je te tutoie j'arrive pas de
vous voyez tout bon ouais c'est vrai que
je vous vois au non j'aime bien le
tutoiement ça va ça c'est comme si on se
connaissait quoi